oh
[Musique]
je veux de grands shows de grandes idées
moi j'ai une idée est spectacle spatial
avec lesquels le web on connaît ses
qualités
personne n'a vu depuis quinze ans je ne
vous décevrai pas monsieur il vaudrait
mieux sinon je vous balance tutoie
tout je rêvais de me produire avec
sortie depuis que je suis tout petit
[Musique]
je savais que tu étais celle où il est
16h 19h fait et maintenant la star de
notre spectacle
aux états
quoi
vous n'avez qu'à recommencer à jouer
les cobayes
chanter quoi
il ne reste plus à lisieux
votez
de grands une magnifique raid
parce que j'ai toujours dit non
on a toujours le choix c'est juste que
j'ai jamais le courage de faire bobo
et ouais calloway on assiste en tête en
route pour le rencontrer en ce moment
même
votre destination sur votre droite sur
ma droite ça marche